a
[Música]
ah
pero el confinamiento por la pandemia
del coi 19 dejó sin empleo a más de 6
millones de peruanos en el segundo
trimestre de este año según cifras
oficiales y las mujeres sufrieron el
mayor impacto de la crisis 1 45.3 por
ciento de ellas perdieron sus puestos de
trabajo mientras que los varones la
caída del empleo llegó al 34.9 por
ciento en conclusión cerca de tres
millones y medio de mujeres quedaron
desempleadas las estadísticas también
revelan que la población de jóvenes
entre 15 a 29 años de edad que ni
trabajan ni estudian llegó al millón 400
mil diversos expertos afirman que dentro
de este grupo son las mujeres quienes
también han sido las más perjudicadas en
este país las mujeres han tenido una
presencia laboral protagónica en los
sectores más golpeados por la crisis
turismo restaurantes y comercio y por si
esto fuera poco ella tiene menos
opciones de salir a buscar trabajo ante
el aumento de las tareas en el hogar
debido a la emergencia sanitaria
[Música]
la pandemia ha afectado la economía de
todos pero las más afectadas han sido
las mujeres según un estudio de onu
mujeres en bolivia siete de cada diez
mujeres se desempeñan en el ámbito
informal eso quiere decir que trabajan
en los sectores de servicios y de
comercio y que durante la cuarentena que
en el caso de bolivia ha durado seis
meses muchas de ellas han quedado sin
trabajo han sido obligadas a tomar
vacaciones o definitivamente han
trabajado sin percibir salarios y a esto
se le agrega que existe una brecha
salarial del 30 por ciento entre hombres
y mujeres entonces la situación de
pobreza de las mujeres en bolivia ha
sido grave en esta cuarentena frente a
esto sin embargo destacan las historias
de las emprendedoras bolivianas que de
una o de otra manera se han reinventado
para alimentar a sus familias durante la
cuarentena ya sea con negocios o algún
otro tipo de actividad que les genere
ingresos
[Música]
según el ministerio de trabajo casi
medio millón de hondureños ha perdido su
empleo o se encuentra en suspensión
laboral debido a la crisis económica
provocada por la pandemia del cob y del
19 el 40 por ciento son mujeres el mayor
impacto desempleo en las mujeres radica
en aquellas que elaboran en el sector
maquila en el comercio la hostelería y
el servicio doméstico también otro
sector vulnerados son las mujeres que
tienen sus pequeñas empresas debido al
cierre total o parcial de éstas a raíz
del cierre también de la economía
provocado en estos meses de pandemia
para paliar esta situación el gobierno
ha implementado algunas políticas como
el crédito solidario que consiste en una
inyección económica a la pequeña y
mediana empresa sin embargo de acuerdo
al foro social de la deuda externa y
desarrollo en honduras la economía
decrecerá al cierre del 2020 entre 1 -
2.7 por ciento y menos 4.4 por ciento
una situación comparable con la crisis
política y además con el paso devastador
del huracán mitch
el 98